i've seen you say some things about
other women it's like you can't just
show up and be hot your tits and ass
will only get you so far you need to
have a good attitude that's true what
are you bringing to the table and you're
saying that a lot of women are too picky
and that's how they're going to end up
single yeah so speak to that a little
bit what women what do they need to
improve on mindset you know
a lot of
the problems with women today are like
their as i said the list
is long you have to do this to that
whatever you know they're for a guy
that's a qualifier yeah to qualify and
you know if they do if they do a little
thing wrong they're out they're toxic
they're this they're [ __ ] it you know
you you have to bring something to the
table too just because you have tits and
ass everybody and you look semi-okay
it doesn't mean you're a good partner it
just means you have tits and ass
like it if you can't do anything you
can't take care of your men you're not
even a particularly nice person he's not
going to be with you nobody's going to
do that titan ass will get you in the
door yeah yeah but a bad attitude will
get you out there yeah exactly listen
beauty beauty attracts attention but
personality catches hard yes 100
i'm i'm i'm like that too
you know if a guy is good looking he
walks in i can say objectively he's a
good looking and then he opens his mouth
and it's like
okay we're not goodbye
because
you know you can be the hottest woman
on the planet and you know you can be
with a guy
and a lot of women go like he cheated
with a way uglier person yeah they do
that sometimes i was like are you sure
it's weight uglier look wise or you just
have an ugly personality maybe that
person he cheated with is a genuinely
nice sweet person and that's why he find
her attractive yeah
and just because you think she's ugly
doesn't mean he think yeah she's ugly oh
yeah to him maybe she's beautiful
amazing loving warm person so if you
like that clip click right here to watch
another or if you want to watch the
entire sauce cast click right here
[Music]